with uh as we test nuclear devices
there's well yeah there's a book called
uh ufos and nukes
that a guy named robert hastings i've
been trying to get him on here but he's
he's not in good health right now and he
can't travel but uh bummer um
he did that whole book basically you
know
studying and detailing all the events of
ufo sightings over the nuclear bases
shutting down the nuclear bases
completely shutting them down
and not and these guys not knowing what
to do um actually
had uh and it's called bent waters in
england
where um they had they didn't have a
crash they had one land
and the commanding officer who was at a
christmas party
was actually this was the second night
they had the event the first night they
had it they told they reported it all
the uh security personnel these are all
military guys all well-trained military
guys on a nuclear facility i
might add so this this is an everyday
guys
they saw it that night they reported it
but they didn't want to say really what
they thought it was they just thought it
was some sort of down vehicle down
aircraft
yeah the next night it came back they
went there to go get him and actually
brought him back
and they these guys actually touched it
put their hands on it um
one of the other sergeants actually saw
it fly above
the area where these th he said we can't
tell you if there's actually
nuclear devices there but it flew over
this one bay dropped the laser down
went through the roof and into the
actual facility didn't detonate anything
but rendered that that bomb was in there
useless for 24 hours we couldn't use it
for
for that period of time we don't know
what what they did to it or how they did
it
so again we're looking at military guys
who aren't trying to start a story
they were trying to protect the base and
not able to do it so and and now
if you go back and start doing a
research on it every
nuclear base has had some sort of
extraterrestrial so again are we back to
the listen we're going to watch what you
guys do to the planet
we can't have you testing this stuff
yeah it's not good for the planet it's
you know bad mojo have you ever heard of
uh
have you ever heard of atomic veterans i
have not
so i forget what it was called but it
was during that period of time
where uh over in i believe
england as well as here in the us they
would
uh they would recruit young young
military
kids like kids like 18 19 20 years old
they would recruit them they would put
them on on uh
like combat vessels like like um
like aircraft carriers or some some [ __ ]
like that some sort of ships
they would bring them out into the ocean
and they were testing nukes
and they were using you know u.s
military kids that enlisted in the
military like as young as
18 years old putting them on these ships
and they were
testing nukes and basically what they
would do is before they would
detonate the nuke into the ocean they
would make everyone
face the other way and they would tell
everyone to cover their eyes
and there was a lot of people who were a
part of this testing
and it [ __ ] them all up for life like
lots of them got cancer and died
majority of them
could never have kids they all explained
vividly like what it was like how like
they had to take off all their clothes
after and like dispose of all their
clothes a lot of them started losing
their teeth
wow um they like when the thing
detonated they described
seeing all the even though their eyes
were closed and they had their hands
over their eyes
facing the opposite way they all
could account for seeing even their eyes
were closed they
saw the skeleton of their bones and
their hands
when it happened and it [ __ ] these
people up some of them are still alive
and they've done interviews with these
guys i just watched an interview
that this kid did where he he uh it was
a documentary he did where he
interviewed probably a dozen of these
guys
and it is the most terrifying [ __ ]
thing well here's the strange part about
that
on every aircraft carrier that i was
ever on they talk about what happens if
a nuke detonates under the boat what
you're supposed to do
oh really so that's and they that
obviously confirms what you're saying
because they know what to do because
they've already done it and they
understand what happens
because the what initially happens to
the bottom of the ship is the floors
buckle
if your feet are touching the floor
you're probably going to get killed
because
the way that the ship comes up the
ground up comes up so quick that uh it
would shatter the bones in your body so
they tell you to grab the uh super
structure above you and get your feet
off the deck
so that would make perfect sense but
again listen when you're in the military
you're expendable
and you're part of the deal we took
shots before going to spain they were
dedicating these nukes like like like
probably
miles away from the ship sure i couldn't
imagine what would be like if a nuke
detonated
under that under the ship like a sub or
something i mean it's ridiculous it's
just ridiculous all the way around
to even think you would survive it first
of all because we always kind of laugh
i'm like
what is that really going to be the
biggest thing on our mind like get your
feet off the deck
right right you know nukes gone off
underneath of us i don't think if we
even heard the new god i'd be surprised
right right so like i say to see that go
on and you listen even when i was on
i was on the uss lexington which was a
trait training
vessel it's actually not a wooden deck
believe it or not out of pensacola
florida
and we would go out for six weeks and
then come back in and all of the pilots
came from corpus christi texas
so they would fly out there and meet us
and they would do all their landing ops
and we would train them to land on boats
and so behind the ship one night and i
was standing back there you then they
they actually call it um
uh uh phytoplankton that would turn
green
and come out from the back bottom of the
ship and these big green balls of light
would get shot out of the bottom of the
ship i'd be staying this has been the
very
rear of the ship called the fan tail and
i would stand back there at night when i
was off and just kind of enjoy the
evenings and these big
green balls so now even today i'm like
were those really
what was those i was looking at that
were there's lots of bio bioluminescent
sea life out especially far out in the
gulf like that
and you listen you've seen along the
shoreline especially like on heavy waves
come in
okay so it was that color okay but these
were big balls dude i mean
like like three or four cars
you know if you put them all together
and put a ball around that big the
overalls
so it wasn't like a film at the top of
the water it was something that was
being shot
almost like something was playing like
in the in the uh in the
the draft of the ship hmm like i said
monster i mean
this is an aircraft carrier so it gives
you an idea it's a big boat i'm sure
there were any guys like fishing like
dragon lions behind the boat
because that's how you that's how you
catch uh what's it called um
i think it's swordfish sailfish yeah no
no swordfish is it swordfish swordfish
you only fish for it at night
oh you drop on your line when you're
when you're fishing form you drop uh
these [ __ ] nightsticks what are they
called the oh the glow in the dark
sticks yeah yep
yep now we actually used to tie our
clothes and put them on ropes and hang
it over the side if we had to wash them
sometimes because they would
they didn't have any fresh water on the
boat so they would say hey watch your
clothes on the side so that's [ __ ]
crazy
that doesn't sound like a very good way
to get your clothes cleaned not unless
you like that salt water
yeah all right at least they were didn't
stink so that was the plus side of it
how far out into
the ocean or how how like far out far
off shore did the boats go
um i mean you wouldn't see shore right
you wouldn't see shore so you'd be
probably out in the middle of the gulf
okay you know and again they were trying
to see if planes were coming from texas
yeah well they were listen they want to
give the guys a full experience so you
know obviously as a ship pitches and
rolls
that's the hard part for the pilot
coming into land so as the ship pitches
and rolls and tries to do what it's
doing
um so they would put us in the deepest
part of the water to try to get the ship
to emulate that because
we were a small aircraft carrier
compared to what they were going to be
landing on
once they made the fleet so right you
know even again going back and look at
these guys that witnessed these these
ufos
throughout actually up and down the east
coast of florida um they were all on
there i think they're on the uss carl
vinson
and they started a video of that did you
give us a video of that one too um
one's on the east coast no no no that
was the one with the that was the one
that was on the
on the uh the planes yeah right now i
think the one the the one that
lieutenant gray saw was the gimbal i
think there's
there's some game on the wall called the
gimbal yeah and um
um that was the one that uh atip came
out and said hey we're gonna show you
this one and we're gonna show you the
other one from uh
david flavor favor yeah so and those
guys have come out
i mean full-fledged they they weren't
they've not been told hey don't talk
about this
he said we were never told not to
discuss it um and so here we are
we're having this discussion other than
now that the pentagon has said hey
we have been dealing with crashed ufo
material they've come short of not
saying aliens they just said ufo so it's
unidentified
which could be anything at that point is
it the russians what's up world you just
watched a clip from one of our
exclusive patreon episodes that's right
you can get weekly
pure uncut content straight from the
jungles of columbia if you want to watch
the full episode make sure you go to
patreon.comconcretevideos
peace